Hello Freak bitches.
I'm calling my brother for you.
So go ahead.
I believe you not,
it's not that I don't believe you,
it's just that he's really funny.
You want to talk to him?
Coc and sort the phone.
He's probably fucking up somebody
transmission.
Was you transmission specialists?
No,
he's a,
he's a fake ass mechanic.
A fake.
A fake mechanic who tell you he knew so
he doesn't really know he's doing here.
Come back.
He'd say you fix cars were really don't.
I mean he ain't went to school for it.
He just be trying some shit.
So he just fucks around.
He fixed my car.
One time I had a um,
I had an SUV.
I Montero so I needed a head job.
So he told me with the spot plus kept
jumping out the engine.
So that jumped out of and you know,
they kept coming out because they needed
to.
He had stripped the um,
the heads on my car.
So instead of saying,
Hey,
I fucked up here,
your heads,
you know,
you need to get a hedgehog.
This boy went on my back porch,
got my bobby q bachelor,
broke that bitch out,
stuck it in the engine and screwed that
gasket back down.
So I was like,
the car still running ragged it,
so I was like,
fuck you.
You taught my $300.
I go to the dealership dollars.
He took a barbecue spatula.
She's attached to.
You're lucky it didn't explode.
He said,
look,
I pull up to the dealership.
I'm not lying.
And the man take the thing.
And he said,
ma'am,
who put a barbecue spatula and your
engine?
I said,
that motherfucker ain't
charge you $300 to put up a barbecue
spatula,
barbecues bachelor.
That cost me $200.
You know what?
I'm real long fire.
Yes,
yes.
He broke that bitch and stuck it in my
end.
Jot is ridiculous.
And I was like,
why didn't you do that motherfucker?
He was like,
I was trying to keep your spark plugs in
your engine.
Did he learn anywhere?
Did he go to school?
He's getting better.
No more specialist.
He's a.
he's at the point when you can trust him
with an oil change and oil change.
Oh,
I will trust my daughter with an oil
train.
No,
just him because he was leaving the
heart.
Just a courts.
This is where they go.
I'll fucking art design.
Yeah.
But he is horrible.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
He's learning.
He's handled.
Draining.
Where does he do it?
All?
In and around.
He got a mobile business.
A mobile business.
As soon as he fuck up your car.
He changed his.
No,
he doesn't.
He really got three.
Anthony's in here.
Oh
fucking hilarious.
So you just fucked up people's cars.
Changes his number and just gets ghost.
Well again,
you know,
my wife's a psychiatrist,
she,
she's dealt with all this kind of stuff
and she laughed.
She just cracks up because she sees it.
She sees it immediately.
And just like her way of dealing with
insanity is laughter and is she works
with what she's worked with all sorts of
people,
but her sort of specialization is loony
bin like one flew over the cuckoo's nest
kind of scenes.
Right.
I,
I remember going in with her the first
time I visited her at work,
she was running a mental hospital with
like double doors and bars over the
windows,
these criminally insane people who had
killed their kids and you know,
like crazy shit.
Right.
And we went in there and I wasn't
prepared,
man.
We went in and it was just like lunatics
and there was this woman like must've
been in her mid fifties lying on her
back in a little nightgown.
No underwear her with her,
like arms and legs,
you know,
like a crab doing a crab thing and we
walk in like this,
you know,
pussy in the whole scene.
Just scared the shit out of me and just
started laughing like,
yo crazy old lady,
what are you doing?
Get up from there.
She just like last.
And the thing that I didn't understand
until I,
I hung out with her is that people who
are psychotic,
no,
they're psychotic.
And so they kind of know how ridiculous
they are.
And as a doctor,
when she laughs,
she laughs in such a loving,
accepting,
I get you kind of way that it creates
this instant rapport and they start
laughing.
Oh.
So it relieves a little tension,
right?
Like it's all okay,
I know you're just another crazy person.
I deal with you all the time and come
on,
it's,
it's Kinda like how,
you know,
like a,
a gynecologist I imagine would have to
sort of be so laid back that you kind
of,
you know.
Okay,
he seen a million pussies.
I like,
it relaxes you in a way,
you know,
I think she does that with,
uh,
with crazy people.
It's normal people who make her really
uncomfortable.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
imagine if you were a gynecologist and
you were super nervous about seeing
someone.
Okay.
I guess we're about to do that.
Hold on the of modern my face.
Let me have a little more wine.
Just another days off
that's happening.
Let's see what you got wrong down there.
I'm looking,
going to use a mirror.
I like.
It's like it's a fucking vampire Medusa.
You can't look in the eyes.
Do you remember back in Boston?
You were out one night with Jennifer and
I was home and I swear to God on my
father's grave,
this happened.
I rented Batman,
the blockbuster
and I put it in and I'm sitting at home
and I'm watching it and then all of a
sudden I see this shadow and then I turn
my head and I see another shadow and I
look up and there's a bat flying around
the apartment and I'm like,
what?
And I'm scared shitless of bats.
Like,
it's like my thing
ever since I was a kid,
my aunt had this bar near her and they
had bats and they would be me.
They were fruit bats and if they bite
you you'll get rabies and you'll die.
And,
and so,
and we would always be outside playing
tag at night and I would fucking,
bats would fly by and I'd freak out.
And,
and so I'm alone in the apartment and as
a bat flying around and Batman is on TV.
And so,
uh,
all I knew is they go in your hair,
which I think is like not even true.
So I put on a baseball cap backwards and
I had on sunglasses and a tennis racket.
Some glad I didn't want them going in my
eyes.
He's going to go for.
So I'm running around the apartment
swinging at him.
He's taken off.
He's like,
you know,
he's just,
they're erratic the way they fly it on a
where they're fucking going and this
goes on for like 10 minutes and then
there's like a standoff and I'm waiting
and then I hear you coming up the stairs
and you came in and you open the door
and you go,
what the fuck?
You do bad in here and you just,
you just grabbed the tennis racket out
of my hand and he walked up and he was
in the window and you just bashed him
once and he just went down and then you
just walked over and you had taken your
hand and just went into the kitchen.
Start eating it.
I'm stay on sunglasses and I remember
that.
That's hilarious.
I probably wouldn't even killed it if
you weren't already trying to kill it.
I think you,
you might.
I call the animal people to come get it
because it looked like it was stunned if
he was actually dead,
had been sick.
Oh,
you mean once I hit it?
Yeah.
No,
it was.
It was probably.
I remember I told him.
Yeah,
I remember.
I'm like,
I'm not going to have this thing suffer.
I don't remember what I did,
but I remember it was some hitting
involved.
I'm pretty sure it was the tennis racket
could have been.
Yeah,
you were fearless.
I was like,
fuck man,
I don't like.